deployment of Russian troops on Belarus
territory and we must call it what it is
it is occupation
has shamed us all by allowing Belarus to
be the Launchpad for Russian missiles
which have killed thousands of innocent
people in Ukraine
now he wants to turn Belarus into a huge
military base in order to terrorize
Ukraine Poland Lithuania and entire
European union and NATO
and they are already talking about the
deployment of nuclear weapons in Belarus
this must not happen
our position is clear
first Belarus must end any participation
in Russia's brutal War
second every Russian soda must leave
Belarus unconditionally
and third all those involved in Russian
attack on Ukraine from Belarus must be
held accountable
dear friends there is another thing
which I also learned
when changes happen they happen quickly
therefore we have two tasks here
first to make those changes happen as
soon as possible and the second we have
to be ready when they do happen
we mustn't give lukashenka any time to
breathe we must keep Relentless pressure
on the regime
when you discuss sanctions don't forget
about lukashenka he is also a war
criminal with a long record of horrific
human right abuses
we must deprive the regime of any
loopholes that he can use to avoid
sanctions
we must stay United
dictators will try to divide us
hukashenka could play his usual card by
trade and political prisoners in
exchange for lift and sanctions don't
buy it
he will take the money and then start to
arrest innocent people all over again
all parties must stand firm on sanctions
we must take we must make the Kremlin
withdraw all Russian troops out of
Belarus out of Ukraine lukashenka might
act like the kremlin's puppet but he
doesn't represent the people
Belarus is not Russia
I ask you today to reject lukashenka's
fraudulent and deadly regime and work
with us to build a democratic and free
Belarus
recognize the United transitional
cabinet as the true representative of
the people
we are ready to cooperate and Implement
joint projects within the Eastern
partnership and other programs
we have already established such
cooperation with the Council of Europe
for the first time in its history the
Council of Europe will not work with the
official government but with our
Democratic movement
[Applause]
so we ask the European Parliament to do
the same with Belarus
you know in one of his last interviews
about Freedom Elizabeth our Nobel Prize
winner said
it's our duty that not only artists or
writers but every Bill Russian should
think about our future how to rebuild
our country how to make our life safe
and prosperous
this is where we need your help the
European parliamentarians help us to
show that Belarus is welcomed in Europe
help us to draft a new Democratic
Constitution and prepare new reforms and
initiatives
provide Builders and students and young
professionals with internships and
scholarships
so help us to shape our future
[Applause]
you know dear friends I believe that a
free Belarus will be the strongest
possible sanctions against Putin's
Terror and the best support for free
crane will be a 1 000 kilometer
protective border with elaborated
Belarus no longer with a Russian colony
I'm sure that the path to peace in
Europe is through freedom in Belarus I'm
sure that the path to peace in Europe is
through victory in Ukraine I know it's
difficult and painful painful path but
it is the right path so let us walk it
together when we work together we are
Europe thank you
thank you
thank you so much dear satyana for these
very moving words very wise words and
Applause showed you how much we support
you and all your colleagues of the
democratic forces in Belarus
we will now have an exchange of views I
will first get the floor to the chair of
the delegation for relations with
Belarus our dear colleague Joseph or
Lakers for three minutes
thank you chair uh Dear Mrs dear
colleagues the guest thank you for
giving me to the opportunity to
intervene today at this committee
meeting in association with the
delegation in relationship with the
Belarus times are difficult and it's
important that various parliamentary
borders dealing with verulose speak with
one voice
I've liked on the line today one simple
fact the political crisis in Belarus has
a strong external Dimension it is not
just a matter of concern for the Courage
the Belarusian people who are fighting
for democracy and dignity it will touch
us all not only
Power for two years in addition he has
Daniel Belarus into the a base for
Russian and paralysts and the Earth
despite the fact that more than 80
percent of Belarusian are actually
opposed to it
to take part directly in their hostages
in Ukraine it is difficult to predict
but will be the Russian dictators next
move and what will demand from his vasal
lukashenka
in this context let me draw your
attention to lukashenka's recent illegal
visit to occupied Georgian region of
afghazi in violation of international
law on Georgia sovereignty and territory
integrity also I would like to mention
that Ukrainian intelligence service
Recon that lukashenka has approved the
deployment of 20 000 Russian troops in
the Belarus which should support us and
this Monday he had ordered belushian
troops to deploy with Russian Force near
the border with Ukraine we cannot
exclude either the deployment of Russian
nuclear weapons onto the Belarusian
territory as I said the internal
external mention of these crisis are
very much linked
this is why I welcome The Creation in
early August of United transition coming
led by Mr tikonovska whom our Parliament
considered to be the real winner of the
2020 presidential election I note with
pleasure that purpose of the
transitional committee are not only to
facilitate a democratic transition and
establish the Constitutional order but
also to defend Belarus Independence and
sovereignty by putting the end to the
the fact occupation of below by Russia
and let me conclude on Warner by saying
that the past months we have fitness
models but real attempt by lukashenka's
regime to reach out to the Western
countries and explore ways to the open
dialogue with us in this respect the you
must remain farm and not fall in this
trap
has said on the control we must maintain
our pressure the assaction and hold
their gym accountable for its numerous
crime thank you for your attention
Belarus
thank you yours us for your good words
and now I give the floor to the sending
wrap a turn Belarus our colleague Petra
thank you David and most welcome
Svetlana and your team to the European
parliament's affect committee it's
always a pleasure to see you and good to
exchange and deep our knowledge and
probably come up with further proposals
on our future operation
continuing Crackdown on opposition and
political prisoners and indeed Civil
Society so we see nothing more as
increasing prosecution and intimidation
it's something what is completely
unacceptable and our reaction must be
appropriate
let me to ask
publicly what some the of the EU member
states representations do in Minsk
what they are looking for why the some
countries member states countries
ambassadors are still in Minsk do they
expect any good from lukashenka
and allow themselves to be humiliated
every time meeting with some indeed
those who are on the site of regime and
not just the EU member states but for
example Swiss
as such and I'm very critical about this
after
the lukashenko regime refused further
accreditation to dirkshubel EU
ambassador to Belarus should we welcome
the Belarusian ambassador to EU
why he is still here
I mean are we are not responding as Mr
Burrell recently said too slow and too
ineffectively are we to read just papers
titles and not to make a policy line
being composed and implemented I call on
the offet to react and to ask for
strengthening our line of uh you know
against the lukashenko regime and
showing all political diplomatic and
other signs which must be you know
strengthened in this regard and yeah
made a very strong statement asking us
to look forward for further and
increased cooperation with the
opposition Democratic opposition of
Belarus
we have to make some steps towards this
and we have to find appropriate means
how not just to recognize we because we
have recognized you I mean there is
nothing more to be done but we have to
establish some uh you know mechanism of
our cooperation
I call in on the European Union indeed
to provide a needed financial assistance
as well as political decision to be made
in order to see
um
Democratic opposition of Belarus
representatives in in in Brussels other
capitals of the European Union as
legitimate representatives of Belarus
thank you Petrus I will now give the
floor to further colleagues we have to
be a bit cautious of time because our
next item will be at quarter past 11 so
we have about 20 minutes left in the
moment I have requests to take the floor
from seven
colleaguese
and Alexander of jordanov ties her out
indeed mccurst and Anna fatiga
if we if we stick to B7 I would say I
could ask you to do two minutes each and
then we have a round of replies from
svetliana
okay two minutes each and we kick off
with Sandra kanyita
thank you two minutes it's too short but
I will try I will begin with very
personal
uh words because this is a woman in
politics former leader of independence
movement of Latvia I admire you and I
know also how difficult it is what you
are doing now all my respect and
admiration and it is evident that
Ukraine will win the war and this
Victory will open also the door for
transformation of Belarus and I hope
Russia
and also for the occupation of Belarus
and there is no doubt lukashenka is a
war criminal I will not repeat what has
been said I co-sign what my colleagues
said but I learned that
Ukraine's defense intelligence recently
reported that Belarus is currently
preparing the accommodation of 20 000
mobilized Russian soldiers and my
questions are are there any signs of
slow but steady increase of draftees
being called up to Belarusian conscript
offices are there measures on their way
to prepare Belarusian infrastructure
Barracks dormitories etc for long-term
use of the airfields close to the
Belarus Ukrainian border could these
preparations indicate a future
intensification of Russian
and Belarusian military cooperation and
do you consider
could you elaborate on how the
structures of the democratic Belarusian
forces look like now
with the reform of coordination Council
and creation of the United transitional
cabinet and to conclude I would join
those who congratulate Alice bellowski
or Nobel Peace Prize thank you
thank you Sandra Tice Wroten
thank you chair and thank you
dearskaya for your decisive European
leadership your fight for sovereignty
democracy and freedom continues to
remind the world that lukashenka is
illegitimate and his regime must go and
the Belarusian people demand change and
the world must stand ready to help the
moment for change finally arrives
so what steps could the European Union
take to help you and your United
transitional cabinet implement this
change my personal opinion is that we
should not look at what we would
normally do because we are not in a
normal situation we need to be creative
and pragmatic in this exceptional
situation to establish a formless
possible link with the transitional
cabinet the fate of Belarus and that of
Ukraine are directly related and your
advocacy demonstrates this politically
like the kalinoski regiment and those
Brave belarusians who sabotaged the 24th
February Invasion demonstrate this in
action now lukashenko lukashenka ramped
up his delusional rhetoric of threats to
Belarusian territory and the regime
grouped with the Russian troops we know
that the vast majority of the Belarusian
people opposes Russia's aggression and
would refuse to fight so what is your
assessment of the likelihood of such
Invasion and what it would do with the
people in Belarus itself and uh the last
Point trade unionists and Civil Society
have played a central role in the
resistance movement to lukashenka and
Putin both at the time of your election
and after the full-scale invasion of
Ukraine but the regime cracks down on
them relentlessly and the European
Parliament adopted a resolution in
support on the Trade union leaders in
May but what further steps can we take
to support Belarusian civil society and
trade unions in particular those
activists who remain in Belarus and of
course I also think with great memory of
the conversation that I had with um
Alice bielitsky two days after the
hijack of the Ryanair plane regretfully
still in prison but I know that he will
be free like Belarus will be free thank
you for your powerful leadership and we
stand with you Xavier bellus
thank you thank you ties
Anna fatigue please
thank you chair Madam
once more thank you for being with us
thank you for sharing your your views
with us I I fully Echo your your
statement and and I pledge to do uh oh I
can whatever is in in my
possibilities to to to support your
requests we have to do
um our best here in the European
Parliament to make relations with the
opposition of Belarus but now of the the
transition unified translational
government and the Brussels office that
you announced as official as possible
not only here in effort but but also in
in other
formats of the European Parliament and
elsewhere in institutions that are based
here in Brussels in our respective
member states as well
um I like to inform that on actual
my requests not only my political group
but it's all also the cop
and other bodies accepted to the
provision of of a topic during the
upcoming planaries session indicating
the active role of wukashenka regime in
supporting Russian war of aggression on
on Ukraine will be able to debate it in
at length the Liberals
thank you next speaker's Michael Gala
thank you very much and it's good to
have you back here in in Brussels and
that we address Belarus issue apart from
the war in Ukraine because it's in
multiple ways interlinked my question
goes in the direction of the Visa issues
that he also addressed and that we
should not stop the issuing of visas and
and my question is in this regard
um is the current situation acceptable
especially for those who would like also
for political reasons like to leave the
country I mean we have easy access for
ukrainians in general Belarus that's not
the case as such but is your practical
impression that all those who need to
leave because they are under repression
that their situation is acceptable to to
get into the EU that's the one question
and the other thing I would like on on
your the coordination Council and now
the new structure so to say so let's say
and kind of government in Exile
um my question is whether you consider
the uh the composition or also the the
representation of the different
Democratic parties is that already uh
where it should be is it inclusive
enough uh and uh if not what what could
be done and if so uh I would welcome
that of course thank you
thank you Mikhail next speakers Did
macusta
speaking German
thank you and thank you madam chicken
coming along to our committee today and
presenting the present situation in
Belarus
I wish you all
strength to continue with your fight
against uh for Democrat democracy and
human rights and the European Parliament
stands with you in all of your efforts
my comments are as follows recently we
have seen that from the Russian side
there is actually an effort to
coordinate more with Belarus trips that
there should be common trips from Russia
and Belarus we see that this is a
further escalation of the entire War how
do you see this matter do you think that
Belarus is going to be sending troops to
this war and do you think that they're
going to be directly involved in the
conflict I know that you yourself were
at the base involved in this Foundation
of an anti-war movement in Belarus and I
know that you have also developed a
number of activities in that vein I know
that you have also been involved in
sabotage against the Russian war machine
in Belarus and there's a lot of
activities that's showing solidarity in
Belarus against the Russian people and
in favor of the Ukraine people so I
would be interested to hear what you uh
would uh your opinion is from the
position of the anti-war movement in
Belarus and do you think that this
movement will be able to succeed and how
what can we do to support you also there
are many refugees from Ukraine going to
Belarus how are these refugees being
treated in Belarus are the Civil Society
activities set up to take in these
refugees and to support them who are
coming in from from Ukraine
thank you the next speaker is Mr
kobilius
well
your colleagues Madam president uhlana
really it's pleasure and honor for us to
have your visit here
definitely you are you know great and I
would encourage you to stay strong
despite the fact that lucasenke is still
you know here somewhere in it means
Democratic Belarus is also know our
interests the interest of EU not only of
Belarusian people
uh it's not very clear you know how we
can for time being removed ashenka but
Ukraine Victory can change a lot
including collapse of lukashankar regime
what we can do inside of you is to help
you and ourselves for the future of
democratic Builders after lucasranka
will collapse and it's really great and
I congratulate that while you
established your transitional government
and traditional government is ready to
establish its representative office in
Brussels that's really big big step
forward
and we in the awareness delegation which
I am leading
uh would be happy that your government
delegation representing Belarus would be
present in the nearest session of Uranus
in December in in in kitchen of in
maldaba so we shall we go to your letter
and I think that together with Joseph we
shall look how to make you know things
happening and then second point I would
say that what we can try to do uh and
this is or not only can try but really
let's do it you know let's elaborate you
know from both sides from our side and
your site some kind of much more clear
strategy what will be relationship of
European Union with you know Democratic
Builders when the change will come what
kind of programs we should need to
establish how we shall move you know to
what's you know Association agreements
and so on and so on so that would be a
really very important job to be done
thank you Andreas and the final speaker
as our colleague jordanov please
[Music]
thank you
chair I will speak Bulgarian
Mrs tikanovskia I really liked what you
said you said that Belarus is not Russia
you also said that
lukashenko does not represent the people
of Belarus
and of course
we should work together with the United
transition cabinet of yellow rose
actually our colleagues had a number of
ideas how this can be organized however
I have a preoccupation I will start with
first
we all know quite well that dictators
will not be there if they're not
supported by their own people
so we should say it clearly we should be
frank
if there is a Putin in Russia in this
war now if there is a luka shenko in
Belarus well then this means that a
large part of the people in Russia in
Belarus are actually supporting these
dictators
and we should Analyze This fact and we
should see what is it that we can do so
that these people can wake up so to say
actually we saw that there are also
other countries that yesterday supported
Russia in the U.N we have
to wake up these people to the values of
democracy and freedom this is an
obligation of the European Union and now
let me move on to my question is there a
real threat that lukashenko sends Bella
Bruce
armies against Ukraine thank you
colleagues for your contributions
may I ask you to sum up in about five
minutes and answer the questions and the
comments the flaws yours madam
uh thank you dear chair and thank you
for all for your remarks and questions
and of course for your warm words of
support
you know two years ago I was speaking
here in effect and it was my first
International visit and in my first
actual speech and since then all time I
feel your solidarity and your support
so let me kindly ask you not to call
lukashenka the president
uh not to call his regime Bill Russian
regime and when you speak about the
aggression against Ukraine it's not
Belarus but lucaschenka's regime who
became calabrant
so distinguish biliruses and the regime
is not the same language actually is
very important
so I will start to answer the questions
with the Ukraine you know we have
different situations but we fade the
same evil at least three Battalion of
Bel Russian military volunteers are on
the front lines in Ukraine at least 15
volunteers have been killed already
many better sense Medics work hard to
save lives of Ukrainian soldiers and
actually civils recently together with
annaliana Byer book we provided their
Mobile hospital to
Belarus and medics in Ukraine
also there are many billion volunteers
who collect evidence of the war in
Butcher and other cities
and today my representative valerica
valeevsky is in Kiev to establish
official relationship with the
governments with
we have already opened office in Ukraine
but we intend to create an alliance
between Ukraine and Democratic Belarus
on the issue of political prisoners and
repressions now after the war has
started repressions intensified and they
are even more than back in 2020 dozens
of people detained every day in Belarus
no communication with the outside world
some people
have known about the war with two months
delay actually
we also know that the cells are full
with the military and officials we don't
know even their names
regime is afraid of betrayal and that's
why they arrest their own people now
which is the sign of uh I would say
desperation in some way
now to help political prisoners so keep
the topic high on agenda adopt uh
sanctions on judges prosecutors those
who who committed crimes against people
in Belarus you can also adopt political
prisoners it's uh it will take five
minutes of your life you know to write a
letter or communicate with the family of
political prisoners but it gives such a
huge energy to people to people inside
Belarus who sacrificed their freedom uh
you know in the sake for of free Belarus
um
but it's evident that without pressure
political prisoners will not be released
so I urge you to put Demand on release
of political prisoners everywhere
on diplomatic presence you know I think
that it's not uh right time to send
ambassadors to Minsk don't present
credentials it's enough to essential
defer but don't
um do anything that will mean
recognition of illegal regime
illegitimate regime instead develop
diplomatic relationships with Democratic
Belarus uh as we you know repeat
non-conventional times need
non-conventional decisions and now it's
time to uh as you have already also
mentioned to be creative to be inventive
and to have a different approach to the
situation
on the issue of Russian troops entering
Ukraine you know we do all possible to
prevent it we campaigned for seven
months to explain uh soldiers you know
why Belarus should support Ukraine and
we felt a positive response you know
ifukashenka decides to send uh bills and
troops to Ukraine or if the if they
force Builds an army to join the Russian
army I think it will be political
suicide for lukashenka our soldiers will
not fight uh with the ukrainians they
will defect they will change sides they
will escape and but anyway we should
continue remind lukashenka that he will
pay a big price if he continues to
support Russian Russian invasion
as for cabinet and coordination Council
uh lukashanka lost legitimacy and
doesn't represent Builders and people
anymore the cabinet aims to represent
interests of belarusans both in the
country and outside cabinet is almost
formed already we have six
Representatives or ministers who work on
different directions the coordination
council is in the process of reformation
continuation Council will play the role
of prota Parliament and its goal to be
in control of cabinet half of the
coordination Council will be
represented by political parties and
have will be represented by ngos
and you know we must develop really
Democratic structures in advance we
shouldn't give any chance a dictatorship
to repeat in our country
and thank you for your comment on visas
it's a very difficult for person people
to get visas in Belarus at the moment
people are often prosecuted even for
having Visa in their passport location
even you know introduced a low
prohibited large group of population to
leave the country
so our goal is to make sure that visas
are available for all people not
involved in in criminal activities of
the regime so we ask you to not to
impose Visa ban opposite help
belarusians to retain connection with
Europe showed that European doors are
opened for uh Builders and people who
are opposing the regime
so again thank you for supporting us and
you actually we have a long list what
can be done but help us to bring regime
to accountability and as I said keep the
door always open for billerson people
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
Parliament here and the effort committee
thank you for your important remarks and
the contributions by colleagues showed
that members of this committee are
following the developments in your
country with great interest
we will continue our close cooperation
with the Democratic forces of Belarus
you can count on our steadfast support
in your struggle for a free and
Democratic Belarus for as long as it
takes shivi Belarus
thank you
[Applause]
we're running late